[Music]
Christmas
time
you
the city is
beautiful in the early morning
[Applause]
air love the smell of
Sunrise and everything becomes so
clear I wish the time would stand still
if this was part of the food
we would watch the clip all day like a
portrait of you and
[Applause]
I like a portrait of you and
I city is
beautiful feel it in the
morning
love
right everything becomes so
clear I think you are
[Music]
beautiful and you know if I one
look did you all my
time when you were going
up
oh your life shows the in
eternity when I take this one CH and fly
with
me just this
one just a second that
soon
[Music]
and when it finally came it wasn't round
for long you acally stumble around one
war second and suddenly
G
one one second
[Music]
suddenly
I wish the time would stand still if
this was part of the
fil we would watch the clip all day like
a portrait of you and
I like a portrait
[Music]
you
City
beautiful feel it in the morning
yeah love smell sun
right
everything BEC so
clear I think you are
beautiful and you know why one
look did you know the
time when you
were life CH the bre in
eternity why I take this one chance and
comply with
[Music]
me just this
one just a
[Music]
second
down